this is not another story about how you
need to come and save Africa in fact my
goal today is to give you reasons to
start to see Africa differently there's
no lost on me that my continent has long
been the world's biggest begging bowl
this is not lost on me that Africa has
long been synonymous with poverty
corruption disease under development in
fact a google images search for the word
Africans will ask you if you actually
meant starving Africans or poor Africans
really try it and so in 2002 I packed my
bags I got that visa i left nigeria fur
for college in the US I was leaving
average incomes of three hundred and
fifty dollars a year that's roughly a
dollar a person I was leaving a country
that had just emerged from the shadows
of 12 years of military rule my
prospects we did yes pack my bags I left
I came to college of the United States
and then Jude a friend of mine asked me
a question that would forever change the
way I understand my relationship about
that he said if it's not you and me
who's Africa is it develop
question kept ringing in my head whose
Africa is it I can get really
comfortable here similarly check out the
accident but there was another part of
me that wanted to take ownership of that
question and so after University I
decided to visit this place I had left
to understand what it was that I was
leaving behind I called my journey
solving Africa it was a trip to seven
countries around the continent that that
name as funny as it may sound to some of
you was actually my answer to June's
question about a week after the site
solving AFRICOM went live I had received
my first fully funded round trip fast
forward six months 53 donations roughly
40 volunteer hours and about ten guest
rooms I'd visited Tunisia Ethiopia Kenya
South Africa Sammy go ghana there was a
story being written across the African
continent it is a story that i began
recognizing at with each country that i
visited it is a story that echoes softly
now but louder and louder every day and
this is it Africa stars are aligning I
see it in the in the way that Africans
relate to Africa I see it in the way
Africans outside Africa are starting to
think of Africa and also in the way that
people who aren't even Africans are
thinking of the continent let me tell
you about Sammy get out i met him in
kenya he lives in nairobi but
specifically in a slum in nairobi called
matara this one matar looks like but all
counts not a place you would want to
live there are open sewers people live
in shacks there's trash everywhere but
Sammy organized people to begin cleaning
public bathrooms around behtari not only
matar e he moved this to how there are
slums in
nairobi pretty soon people in those
lumps said no stop it's okay we can
clean our own bathrooms and they
organized their own toilet cleaning
programs and then okay he moved back to
my tari and Tammy thought to himself I
would really like Matara to become the
Hollywood of Kenya I know what he did he
got donations for computers for books
for video equipment and when foreign
exchange students or aid workers came to
observe what was going on a matar a he
got them into his own work when I
visited matar II this is what I saw and
this is right next to the picture I just
showed you Sammy's place he calls us the
material resource center is slept on the
right he lives there with his wife but
on the Left there's there are teenagers
at least when I was there there we
teenagers who are recording their first
music video this is what Sammy built and
this amazing change is not just hacking
among Africans who've never left people
who have left are starting to return but
before we get to that story African
immigrants in other countries send home
at least in twenty eleven twenty seven
billion dollars and of course I know
where a Silicon Valley when these
buildings are everywhere these companies
thank you for letting contacts that is
larger than the GDP of 93 countries
African immigrants though of course you
expect that people will send money home
it's what you do when you leave but not
just people who have sent money home
through others many Africans starting to
return and build businesses in Africa
I'm tell you about this man his name is
Teddy Wilson billete now let's say is
from Ethiopia had lived about 20 years
in Boston before deciding he was going
to go start a spa and addis ababa a spa
I didn't know about you but when I think
spy don't think definitely not one of
the world's poorest countries no I mean
come on um but he did this this is what
he built and not just the spa a few
years later that had grown into hotels
and resorts all over Ethiopia
he did this and today employs roughly
700 people and counting I can tell you
more stories like Teddy goes I tell you
about done lady verheiden in Nigeria are
you talking about Fred Swan occur a GSB
alum in South Africa why even about
Patrick a [ __ ] in Ghana we don't have
that much time though so let me talk
about the third thing I mentioned the
way that the discourse is changing among
people aren't even actors growing up I
came to understand that Africa has often
been the world's charity case right many
people saw my continent as this
unfortunate place and needed to come to
the top of my hapless hapless home but
that does that that is actually changing
because now instead of seeing resources
people see resourceful partners foreign
direct investment has gone from 11
billion in 2002 when I left to 40
billion in 2012 companies like IBM GE
Microsoft's they've all set up shop it's
clear things are changing in Africa so
now when I think of Nigeria and remember
how afraid I was how kind of despondent
I was about the future that's all
changed now because I look forward to
going back to Nigeria I'm excited my
friends call me often and say hey what
are you coming back when is this
happening and they're not alone it's not
just in their minds lenders average
income went from two three hundred fifty
dollars in 2002 thirteen hundred dollars
now not just that life expectancy
growing at half a year six months every
new year so just by virtue of being in
Nigeria now you wait one new year and
your life is extended six months
and then remember when I talk about
military rule we've had three successful
transitions of power yes the stars are
aligning things are happening how
awesome would it be to look back and to
tell your kids that you were a part of
that story Africa is going to change
dramatically in our lifetime that's how
fast things are happening so my call to
action today is find your place in that
story to the Africans in Africa keep
dreaming to those siblings of Senegal
that young man in Ethiopia die young
woman in Ghana the odds are finally in
your favor to Africans who don't live in
Africa it's clear that your remittances
make a lot of difference but what
matters exponentially more is when you
move back your ideas your expertise your
inspirations of people on the ground and
to all of you although you may not be
African although you are 10,000 miles
away from the continent what you do and
say and think also matters so when you
see Africa do you see a placement pitied
or place to invest when you think of
Africa you think of problems or
opportunity when you see us do you see
charity or dignity thank you